well Transit bus drivers admit they're
scared every time they get behind the
wheel not scared of Road accidents but
the danger they deal with inside their
bus and this comes after the bus union
says on Wednesday a passenger was shot
inside an RTC bus a news now reporter
Victoria Saha with reaction from a
driver who says enough is enough
RTC bus drivers drop off and pick up
passengers multiple times a day
is getting on and what they're capable
of doing it seems like this that scare
Leo Henderson he's concerned he could be
the next Target of a violent crime all
we want is for our drivers to be treated
with dignity Henderson has been a bus
driver with RTC for four years he's
witnessed a lot we can spit on
okay we got we get thrown urine last
week a bus Supervisor was stopped at the
Bonneville Transit Center in February a
man died after being stabbed multiple
times cameras capturing it all on
Wednesday a shooting on a bus what is
that camera gonna do just catch a
picture Henderson wants more safety
measures so much so he plans on running
for state senate my constituents don't
want to ride the bus my drivers don't
want to ride the bus either Pilots
the flight attendants have Marshalls
and they have TSA
we should have the same protection he
says the bus drivers deal with all kinds
of passengers including those that
refuse to pay most of the drivers are
just letting them go through and just
say hey look I want to go home safe